most investors are looking for
governments or looking to invest in
countries where the government has a
clear agenda of how it's going to grow
the economy over a multi-year period
very often the what's been quite clear
from the past to the historical
circumstance very often African
governments do not have much of a role
in in that putting that experience
together bring those plans together and
so many investors look at Africa and say
hmmm this place must be a basket case
because rather than really doing the
hard work so trying to finance economic
development from from other sources such
as foreign direct investment or the bond
market survey transparent the the past
tradition has been for African
governments to raise money through the
World Bank and and mall and the
bilateral donors which is quite opaque
nobody knows you know which country is
doing better than another country
because it's all kind of closed and
information is not very clear on how
these countries are doing so this has
actually discouraged private investors
coming in moreover because of the
bureaucracy and the lack of focus or an
incentive for governments in in Africa
to try and raise money from other
sources we find that it becomes so
difficult to start a business for
example in Africa for some countries it
takes up to two years to get a business
license and that to me is an artifact
again of a system where the government
doesn't really need to find other ways
of raising money there okay to continue
to sustain the bureaucracy because
there's there's money coming in from
from aid
well the good news is that we're seeing
a new crop of African leaders coming up
who are questioning the aid system and
recognizing that it's not such a good
system for the delivery of long-term
economic growth and the reduction of
poverty so for example at the extreme
we've got places like South Africa and
Botswana that do not rely on aid to the
extent that other African countries do
but we also have countries like Ghana
which are making strides away from aid
and towards more private capital
solutions to finance development more
recently I spent some time in Rwanda and
President of Rwanda mr. Kagame President
Kagame has been very vocal about how aid
doesn't work and how he's desperately
trying to find ways to wean his country
off of aid and there needs to be much
more of that but there are African
countries where we're actually beginning
to hear this dialogue it's a great pity
that many of these African leaders who
are much more innovative in how they're
looking at financing development and
reducing poverty in their countries
don't really have an international
audience we don't hear that much from
them but they have very clear plans on
what they're going to do one of the
things that very easily a country can do
for example is to look at getting a
credit rating of which currently only 15
out of about 50 African countries have
credit ratings and yet Critter rating
that a prerequisite to access the
international capital markets oh that's
just a specific example of what I
believe is a space for a lot more
improvement in in moving away from Aid
you